este hotel ubicado en el centro de cuba
cuenta habitualmente con una alta
ocupación en este periodo del año pero
esta vez los turistas fueron
reemplazados por personas contagiadas
con kobe el establecimiento se
transformó en un centro hospitalario y
enfrenta desde hace varios días un flujo
incesante de pacientes los contagios
están disparados en la provincia de
ciego de ávila y las autoridades han
registrado casi 100 fallecimientos en
tan solo 24 horas la isla acumula más de
3 mil decesos desde el inicio de la
pandemia la tasa de incidencia en la
isla con una población de 11.2 millones
de personas es de 1.141 personas por
cada 100.000 habitantes la situación
está complicada en el cub a esto debido
a
la variante venta que ha sido reportada
por las autoridades en varios lugares
del país que hay todavía una cantidad
significativa de población susceptibles
mientras tanto las autoridades inoculan
a la población apresuradamente las dos
vacunas más desarrolladas abdalá y
soberana comenzaron a ser utilizadas
incluso antes de ser homologadas la
primera tendría una eficacia contra el
comités y nueve de más del 92% después
de tres dosis según el gobierno
digamos de pico pero que realmente vaya
disminuyendo progresivamente todas las
personas hasta que lleguemos ya la
ansiedad la memoria del rebaño la
inmunidad de rebaño que estamos buscando
que a su vez lo estamos haciendo a
través de la vacunación a la isla bajo
sanciones estadounidenses trabaja con
sus propias vacunas que corresponden al
80 por ciento de su programa de
inmunización